these gowns were not designed to set
style trends nor did they come from the
shops of commercial stylists as a matter
of fact they were not designed to set
style anywhere yet the good taste they
reflect may well influence what's wore
in the world round while they were
created for only one woman the woman who
wears them yet they may be and often are
adopted individually by millions of
others for these are creations of the
high art and skill of the motion picture
costume designer whose sole function is
to provide appropriate dress for motion
picture stars and featured players a
vital contribution to the transformation
of a human personality into a specific
screen character in the one word
appropriate lies the essence of the
costume designers problems and of his or
her talent skill and knowledge or no
matter how simple a costume it must be
right no matter how complex a cast
wardrobe it must be right no matter how
minor a close detail it must be right to
the costume designer who is responsible
for these and many other considerations
being right means being right on three
major counts historic Geographic and
dramatic historical accuracy presents no
major problem since Hollywood's costume
design departments are well stocked with
source material with factual description
and illustrative sketches drawings and
photographs to follow the costume
designer can easily provide us with a
well-turned out caveman an authentic
Roman crowd
properly gown turn-of-the-century chorus
girls or any other historically
authentic characters ranging all the way
from before the time of the Crusades
down to the present day other volumes
sketches and illustrative material in
the vast reference libraries of the
studio's make geographic accuracy also a
fairly routine affair for instance what
would be the proper apparel for an
ancient Spanish printer a chemist or an
African witch doctor up comes the answer
translated with faithful accuracy to the
screen by the costume designer the same
for a well-turned out Eskimo an
Argentine Gaucho a Mexican pearl diver
or any other character in any other
locale dressed appropriately for the
location where the action takes place as
well as for the historical period where
the costume designer contributes most is
in providing those values which make
costumes right dramatically here the
problems to be solved are often most
difficult and elusive and to create
appropriate answers the costume designer
must work almost all together with
intangibles with ideas judgment
intuition feelings and taste in the mind
of a designer the creation of a gown
starts with these abstract elements
during the very first stages of film
planning or that is when the costume
designer begins work on any given
assignment sitting in with a producer
director art director cameraman and if
the picture is to be in color with the
color coordinator it is in such
conferences that she begins to work out
answers to those important intangible
problems which face her
in the case of our example her thoughts
and planning may well have followed a
pattern like this let's see now
girl is young about 20 her sweetheart
has just left her after a quarrel she's
going out this evening with another boy
her friend at the family who means
nothing to her
how would she dress sombrely because
she's unhappy about the quarrel or
should she be characterized differently
from address point of view I wonder if I
shouldn't dress her in a manner to help
cover up her unhappiness saying
something white and gay and sparkling
what about material Jersey perhaps
embroidered in sequins in the story she
does come from a family of means but
there's no false note there a dress like
that would give her an heir to make her
look defiant at the same time alluring
but wait a minute she cries just before
she leaves for her date that's a big
emotional moment and deserves all the
emphasis we can give it we don't want
the audience to be more interested in
the gown that in the character on the
scene better make the garden less
extreme so it won't detract from a girl
chiffon then attractive but not as glam
buoyant as the other dress
it's summertime too so chiffon would be
appropriate suits your character too
adds to it in fact she does wear it well
and it will be striking in the moonlight
good chiffon it is and so the costume
designer establishes the basic elements
of appropriate dress for that scene for
other scenes well the same process again
and again after that scene after scene
through the entire action of the film
with all the dramatic historical and
local requirements fixed in mind our
designer is now ready to crystallize and
integrate her facts intuition and skill
rough sketches first of all key scenes
at her commander years of background and
experience schools academies colleges in
Paris or Brussels or New York or London
or anywhere else in the world a
successful design business of her own
generally which brought her to
Hollywood's attention in the first place
and a flair and knack which stamps her
creations with individuality and force
other opinions now on the rough sketches
Willy's wardrobe items do their best in
contributing to the film's effectiveness
helped to give it character and impact
emphasize this that or the other facet
of the screen character being created in
short are they right on all counts for
the job to be done
if so they are approved by everyone
concerned this is the official go-ahead
and here another important talent of the
costume designer comes to light a very
practical one which shows itself on the
back of these sketches in the form of a
complete cost breakdown for each
particular gown frock ensemble or
whatever the wardrobe item only now can
the wardrobe department under the
supervision of the costume designer
proceed with its job of producing
costuming for one or a dozen a hundred
or a thousand characters to be created
within the framework of a single
feature-length picture and only now the
costume designers art can take tangible
form and material color drape and line
only now does a gown become a gown
moving out of its conception as an idea
or a sketch with the film in production
the costume designer continues on stage
keeping a watchful eye on the costumes
she has designed making last-minute
improvements making sure that her
creations reveal to best advantage the
purpose for which they were designed
maintaining a constant surveillance from
first scene to last
only when production ends does her
assignment end only to begin all over
again as new pictures go into production
to claim her expert attention to making
wardrobe right and to call up all the
costume designers skillful blend
effectual knowledge and artistic
creative ability to contribute in subtle
ways and in spectacular ways to your
film enjoyment
you